good morning Hank it's Tuesday
obligatory greeting from a hotel room so
last week Sarah made a brilliant art
assignment video about how extremely
wealthy people can sometimes use art
collection as a strategy to avoid
taxation and it got me to thinking about
how in general a lot of the US tax code
seems to affect everyone but in fact
mostly matters only to rich people okay
so let's imagine four families with two
parents and two kids family one makes
$35,000 a year family two makes the
median US household income of fifty nine
thousand dollars per year family three
makes the average earn by the wealthiest
10% of US households $295,000 and family
four makes the average earned by the
wealthiest 1% of US households 1.2
million dollars so in the US we have
these things called deductions which
allow you to deduct a certain amount
from your taxable income like many
business expenses are tax deductible so
if you make say a hundred dollars a year
selling posters but they cost twenty
dollars to print your taxable income
would be reduced to 80 dollars but
critically every taxpayer in the United
States can take the so called standard
deduction which was created to simplify
the tax code so that most people don't
have to list their deductions they can
just take the standard one in 2018 the
standard deduction for each of our
hypothetical families will be $28,000 or
$14,000 if you're single so no matter
what each of our four families gets to
take $28,000 off of their taxable income
which also means that unless your other
deductions exceed $28,000 you don't get
a tax break from them example most
charitable contributions are deductible
in the US but if each of our families
gave 8% of their income to charity only
the family in the 1% who would donate 96
thousand dollars would see their taxable
income go down as a result of charitable
contributions alone now because for the
rest of them their donations would be
below $28,000 now of course the rich
family did give much more in dollar
terms to charity but they're also the
only one of our four families to
essentially receive a government subsidy
in exchange for that donation this
deduction does incentivize charitable
giving among rich people and without it
charities would receive much less money
but I think it's worth remembering that
every time you see someone's name in big
letters at an art museum or a medical
research facility 35 percent of that
money would have otherwise gone to the
government it would have gone to build
roads and pay soldiers and reduce the
deficit probably not side note you might
think these tax breaks would make rich
people super generous but no
families making between 45 and 60
thousand dollars a year on average give
between 3.5 and 4 percent of their
income to charity those making between 1
and 5 million dollars a year give on
average between 2.8 and three point two
percent another popular tax deduction is
for interest paid on your mortgage which
is supposed to incentivize people to buy
homes although in practice it mostly
incentivizes rich people to get
mortgages to illustrate my point let's
imagine that each of our four
hypothetical families in addition to
giving 8 percent of their income to
charity owns a home that costs 4 times
their annual income assuming no other
deductions our family making $35,000 a
year gets no tax breaks for their
mortgage or their charitable giving
because they're much better off with the
standard deduction as is our family
making fifty nine thousand dollars a
year and our family in the top 10% also
doesn't benefit much their taxable
income goes from two hundred sixty seven
thousand dollars with the standard
deduction all the way down to two
hundred forty nine thousand dollars
without it that reduces their total
federal tax bill by about forty three
hundred dollars just over one percent of
their income
our family in the one percent meanwhile
would save over forty thousand dollars
on their tax bill translating to over
three percent of their total income now
some families may have other deductions
especially around medical expenses and I
should note that home ownership and
charitable giving are good things for
governments to encourage but I think
it's worth remembering that these tax
deductions mostly benefit wealthy people
and by far the greatest benefit both in
terms of absolute dollars and percentage
of income is reaped by the richest one
percent of US households if you want to
learn more about taxes specifically the
shocking truth about art and taxes I
highly recommend Sarah's art assignment
video on the topic Hank I will see you
on Friday that's oh that's been coming
oh yeah I'll see you on Friday